[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fabrice je pense que vous un peu marre
de la promo des questions qu'on avantage
tout le temps du coup je vous ai près
mâcher le boulot je vous pose des
questions mais vous êtes déjà le bout de
la réponse vous avez qu'à compléter donc
il faut absolument aller vous voir en
spectacle parce que parce que je crois
que c'est la dernière fois qu'on verra
sur scène avec des cheveux bien où j'en
suis là c'est assez catastrophique
il a ainsi dit qui se dessine et film
[Applaudissements]
trois points gagnants une belle de
chauffe en gagnant quatre points
gagnants vous avez votre à catane où
c'est beaucoup plus facile
les jeunes d'aujourd'hui sont quand même
des gros fils de [ __ ] il chante ça il
chante ça vous répondre il va falloir se
mettre nos deux amis chanteurs c'est là
c'était soprano mais alors il valait
mieux aller ça dites le
[Rires]
en cinq mois c'est parti georges
charbonnier pas je laisse les créateurs
que castle accompli un pas vers
l'égalité et enfin c'est votre cas avoir
un père gynéco ça permet de faire des
gosses pour moins cher
ça rigole pas vous sinon ça bien avant
tout j'ai envie qu'on se fasse le petit
action vérité tous ensemble avec
véronique chabrier bouée à une boule
noire accueille bien axé action
vous allez devoir faire une déclaration
d'amour à gilles verdez les yeux dans
les yeux sa carnation
les traits de son visage tout m'inspire
l'amour ses cheveux qui volent au vent
parce que le ventilateur de l'émission
vient te rafraîchir ses yeux qui semble
dire embrasse-moi fabrice en mangent ils
tu n'avais pas ce grand nez je
t'embrasse ray
[Applaudissements]
e
ca
[Musique]